rebounded by Harris Hutchison had 21
points and that lost Indiana on
Wednesday night gets the story started
with a three ball not exist right now
for Garrett empty so we said it till it
comes back the address you anything
given go perfection the fro on the dish
to Kyrie Irving is winding down he needs
some help down to three down to two
Irving makes his move finishes on a
great cut to the rim here's the give and
go as the shot clock was winding down
gets ahead of his man a t12
[Music]
national title in 2016 with Villanova
the most outstanding player in the Final
Four
Irving takes him on a big slot at
Frank's at home Freddy play from Kyrie
Irving and look at Kyrie Irving just
blows right by art Cynthia hesitation
Irving good defense intercepted by love
her look hurt the strides gives it up
for Kyrie Irving
excellent job defensively straight up he
is his horse Ron didn't helping out
carries the birth rate Bentley to try
and figure out what combinations will be
able to work the Nets though doing a
good job of staying on the attack
perfect lines it up
that's the foul Kyrie Irving heavier
Vings the one the Steelers show early on
once again perfect from the field so far
Gordon has said he will compete to me
that might have been the best slam dunk
competition that we've seen have been
obviously Dominique Jordan was one of
them Kyrie Irving rebounded by Harrison
ten seconds left comparison all the way
missed it whips it down the floor and
Kyrie Irving got a touchdown from Torian
Prince lievable let's start with the
pass by Tory and Prince it is Super Bowl
weekend to finish by Irving Irving is
not an honest
[Applause]
he is not human he's the quickness of
his hands pushes it up locked in perfect
for the half Kyrie Irving